we raise a lot of baby chicks here and
one really important thing is to make
sure that they have access to water and
to make sure that they can't drown in
the water so i'm going to show you today
how to make a chick water that is safe
for very very small chicks what i like
to do is use a shallow tray like this
and then use another container
that will also hold water so the first
thing i'm going to do is poke some holes
in the bottom of this container i'm
going to place it on the plate here and
just make sure i poke the holes below
the top level of where i want the water
to be
so now that i have all my holes in this
jug i'm going to go ahead and put some
water in the tray and then i'm going to
fill this jug up with water as well
i filled the jug all the way up
and i'm going to put the cap on
and then set it down in the water when
the water level gets down to the holes
the water will refill the tray back up
all right let's get the chickie some
water
come on look it's water
come on